my eyes are brown
they're on the smaller side I think my
eyes sparkle they're kind of like a poop
brown I would say that they were
monolids which are also called single
eyelids which means I don't have a
crease or fold I know a lot of people
who have used the double eyelid
contraptions I have used eyelid products
to try and correct my monolid the
endgame for that generally is for young
girls and boys to get eyelid surgery I
guess I want to see what I look like
with double eyelids eyelid trainer
they look like upside-down glasses so
you're supposed to put them over your
eyes like this I look like a [ __ ]
idiot oh my god there we go now I'm
beautiful you can't really blink with
these on
with the repeated use like it's supposed
to permanently change your face but I
don't really believe it I don't think
this face is that malleable you know
what I would use this product if you
gave me six-pack ABS my charm eyelid
teeth I don't go blind this will be a
success you somehow put the little white
part onto the green stick and then just
shove it in your eyes just poke at it
until you get the right shape this is
like it was like a Clockwork Orange
that's where it does if I had double
eyelids maybe I'd be too beautiful
before the world what's a bad [ __ ] look
at that look that whole [ __ ] it created
a line hold the skin over um yeah so it
it's stuck but I look crazy it's another
version of me that I don't think is
necessary better looking I think for me
it's just strange blue you want me to
put glue on my eye if this gets in my
eye will I go blind yeah
all right let's doing this is the
product that I used in high school and
if I remember correctly I needed to use
like a lot of glue is important to [ __ ]
right here it's so much easier to just
love what your mama gave you oh no this
is it it's stuck that's like two seconds
no what what a world we live in we can
alter the shape of your face however you
want to as soon as I put it on I'm just
like oh yeah like I remember why I use
that and it's like I don't think anyone
else would notice the difference in my
face except for me
let's freak me out
this really freaked me out cuz I don't
even recognize the person I'm looking at
in this mirror I feel like a more
accepting of my monolids because it's
just made me realize how much I don't
care about having double eyelids I
started using these products when I was
younger and I was a lot more insecure
and now that I'm an adult I think I
should probably be at this place where
it's like oh yeah like I'm totally cool
and I don't feel insecure about my eyes
anymore and it's like obviously that's
not totally true I'm wondering if it
would have been worth like getting the
double eyelid surgery when I was younger
and I don't think so cuz I like my eyes
the way they are for those who are
struggling with their looks just
remember that there is a lot of people
out there who don't share the opinion
that you have to have a double eyelid to
look beautiful